[Music]
our first talk is on our markdown driven
development
please join me in welcoming emily
[Applause]
riederer
[Applause]
all right hi everyone thank you so much
for coming my name is emily reader
and i'm here today to talk about our
markdown driven development
i assume many of us in this room are
already familiar with our markdown
and what an amazing tool it is for
literate programming and combining both
code and narrative
in plain text to create an amazing
variety of different types of outputs
but something i'm particularly
fascinated by
is how our markdown can also be used as
a prototyping tool
for more advanced analytical tools
i contend that any analysis that you've
created
in our markdown document actually
contains a latent
underlying implicit package or
analytical tool
that is custom tuned to solve
your domain-specific workflow from
everything from
dealing with custom nuances in your data
to making the specific types of
deliverables
that the customers of your analysis need
and the goal of our markdown driven
development is to take this
implicit tool and make it an explicit
one
we'll do this by harvesting all the
assets that you've already created
in that implicit tool for example from
the development side
you've already probably had to go
through and curate a wide set
of packages that relate to your problem
and play nicely together
and you hopefully have developed in your
one-off analysis
a consistent set of code that works to
solve your problem
and ideally is at least somewhat well
tested and um
well styled but beyond pure code
development that we have to work with
we also have a lot of great design
elements already in place
one of the hardest parts generally of
creating a software product
is understanding the user requirements
and getting deep empathy for user needs
but as the person that did the original
our markdown analysis
you get all of that for free you
understand how all the pieces of
analysis
need to come together a sane workflow
for doing the work
and processing your data and again
answering those
questions that are important to the
people that you want to share your
analysis with
and finally you have already a complete
and compelling marketing example
of how your latent tool goes into use
and can solve real world problems in the
wild
so there are five main steps to our
markdown driven development that i want
to talk about today
but and along the way we'll talk about
how
these steps can result in many different
types of outputs and many different
types of analytical products
you can think about producing
well-engineered single files
projects or packages and while i depict
this as a spectrum
i think it's important to call out at
the beginning there's not necessarily a
clear
value judgment in here there's no better
or worse in terms of
quality user experience or your talent
as a coder
depending on what part of the spectrum
you stop at
really all it is and we'll see as we go
through this
is whether you want to tune your final
analysis tool
more to solving another instance of your
very specific problem
or a tool that solves more of a generic
class of problems
so now we'll go through the steps of our
markdown driven development
one at a time the first step's pretty
easy because we don't actually have to
generate anything new
we just simply have to delete a lot of
things that shouldn't be in our markdown
to begin with
so for example some of these things
might include
hard-coded variables which are common
when we're doing
a one-off analysis but thinking about
ourselves or a future user they might
want to update this analysis later
on it can be really detrimental to have
hard-coded variables
late in our analysis that users may not
realize
wonder where they have to change or even
worse they might change them
inconsistently
some places and not the others and
introduce inconsistencies in their
analysis
instead our markdown parameters let us
front load all of this
in the yaml header of your markdown
document
which means that it's very easy for a
future user to see exactly in front of
them
what changes they need to make and have
everything flow on through your analysis
effectively then your entire markdown is
acting kind of like one mega function
through which everything can flow this
is also an effective strategy
for dealing with credentials that you
might not want in your final output
in case you end up sharing your code
with a colleague and even just for good
data security practices there's really
great synergy here with the rstudio ide
because if you click knit with
parameters you can get a nice little
pop-up box
and replace dummy credentials in your
header with your actual credentials
so you've never hard-coded them anywhere
next up
i think we already learned from jenny a
little bit this morning
about file paths and we know that we
don't want to include
global file paths in our markdown
because it makes it very unresilient
to working in the future local file
paths are slight improvement over these
but can still break as we change across
operating systems
or later on as we move our files around
inside of our working directory
so best of all we can use the here
package to create
very resilient file paths to make sure
our analysis
always works as planned and finally and
this step is by far the hardest for me
sometimes we have to kill our darlings
you can't let your markdown
be a drunk drawer for code that you
wrote rabbit holes you went down
that you really really thought would
work but then didn't end up being the
direction your analysis went in
take this time to remove package loads
that you didn't need
and delete code experiments that you
maybe have commented out in your code
just to create a very clean
script with a lot of hygiene on which to
proceed with your refactoring
the next step in our markdown driven
development is simply rearranging your
code chunks
what our markdown is great because it
allows us to capture our thought process
as we go through our analysis but the
one downside of this is our thought
processes are rarely linear
and as a result often neither are the
resulting markdowns the strategy here
is to move to the top a lot of the heavy
duty infrastructure and computing trunks
these can be things that set up our
environment such as library loads
data loads and a lot of our heavy duty
computation with data wrangling
date cleaning model fitting etc and
let's sink down to the bottom the more
communication and narrative aspects
this has many benefits first of all it
allows us
users to clearly see the main
dependencies of our script
at the top as we have things like
external file references
and package loads right where the user
opens the document
similarly by grouping like pieces of
code together we can more easily start
to see
patterns throughout the code and get a
sense where we can later consolidate
and finally often we'll be working on an
analysis with colleagues that don't code
and having all of the more narrative
elements consolidated at the bottom
may make it easier for them to find
places where they can actually jump in
and edit the text parts in our markdown
without being kind of intimidated by
large blocks of code
sprinkled throughout again there's
another great opportunity here to
leverage the rstudio ide for even more
synergy and take advantage of some tips
like naming your chunks and commenting
your code
with the quadruple dash as you see in
this example
the combination of these two features
allows you to create a really friendly
nice table of contents
that you can pop out to help a user
navigate your script better
and jump to the exact component that
they want to work on
so after we've done all of this
rearranging one of the main benefits of
that
is it can more easily help you
understand related parts of your script
and find places where we can cut out
duplicate code and replace these with
functions
for an even more streamlined approach
as a somewhat trivial example of this in
an exploratory data analysis part of
your workflow
you probably end up visualizing the
relationship between multiple variables
in a lot of related plots doing this
without functions
leads to a lot of code that's both
repeated and efficiently
but also makes it harder to tell exactly
what piece of those lines is changing
all i'm actually changing there is the
variable being plotted on the y-axis
but it kind of takes some staring at it
to tell instead breaking these parts
separate trunks
to define my function and then to use my
function gives me numerous benefits
first if i want to change something
about those plots like
theme i can easily just add change that
code in one place
instead of multiple places and secondly
from a
more literate programming perspective
it's much easier
in the view on the right to see what
stayed the same
versus what's changed between iterations
this is also a good time to start
thinking about adding in
our oxygen 2 comments to your our
markdown
for those that haven't ever built
package our oxygen 2 is the tool that
you'll use
to document functions and create the
help pages that we've all
likely seen at some point when we've
pulled out up our documentation
but even before you're building a
package you can easily in the r studio
ide
add in this our oxygen to skeleton and
use that to document your function
this is nice because it's a format that
users are already used to seeing
and gives them the content they expect
to know about a function
it can also help you think more
critically about the design of your
functions
because it forces you to almost make a
contract with yourself about precisely
what those inputs
and those outputs ought to look like
so now that we've cleaned up the actual
content of our code a lot
one final step to think consider at this
point is also cleaning up the style
and we have many gradar packages to help
out here
including the lintar styler and spelling
packages
linters and stylers help us adhere to a
specific style guide
for our script by either flagging
for us to change or by proactively
themselves
editing our scripts to make them a tier
to certain rules such as rules about
spacing and indentation
and spelling similarly can help us
sketch typos in our code
for the cleanest possible view of our
report
so going through all these steps we've
now really
done a lot of work to move our our mark
down
to something that's pretty sustainable
pretty readable pretty navigable
and in some cases this in and of itself
may be a really good stopping point
resource constrained environments if you
don't have a good way to share files
with colleague
a single file can be very easy to send
if you don't have
access to a good version control system
it can be very easy to just take a diff
between versions
so there are some benefits to leaving
things in a single file
finally you can also quickly refresh
your code by just running one single
file in isolation
however these still can be sometimes
lengthy
monolithic and sort of intimidating to
new users
and you may actually be forcing our mark
down to do a lot more computation than
necessary
anytime you want to know so if these
sound like problems to you
we may want to consider moving from a
file
to an our project and our project looks
something like this
and at a high level our goal is to take
a lot of the assets we have
in our single file our markdown document
and break them apart and modularize them
into many different folders
with semantic meaning this can be very
helpful
if you or your organization uses a very
standardized file structure across
projects because everyone will know
where to find specific data assets
within a project
for example one structure i like is
shown here on the screen
where i would save my actuar markdown
report and the output of that
in my analysis folder i put a lot of
those like functions that i defined
and other little bits of r codes such as
those that read and process data
in a variety of our scripts in my src
folder
and i can save both my raw data
as well as like data artifacts that i
create throughout the process
in different data folders and finally
it's a good place to have catch-all
files
for different types of documentation or
external pieces of context
this allows me to create a much leaner
markdown where i just read in the
minimal amount of resources
from these files that i actually need
to take two more specific examples of
what this looks like
instead of have defining both a function
and calling that function in the same
hour markdown
i can break that up and define my r
function
in a modularized script that could be
easily
stolen and repurposed in another
analysis
and i could simply load that in by
executing that code
remotely with the source function in
myor markdown
another big kind of step change benefit
by
going through this process is in your
actual data processing
instead of doing all of your data
processing within your art markdown
i tend to think about doing it in three
different steps
first i use some r scripts to access my
data from my database through my api
or wherever that data is coming from and
save that raw data in a read-only data
file
then through again a variety of r
scripts that might help me
with a lot of my data cleaning and
wrangling and model fitting
i can create a lot of small smaller data
artifacts
and have only those be what i read into
my are markdown
this means that i can run my markdown
much faster
without having to like repeat many long
lengthy simulations or model builds or
whatever it is you may be doing
if i just want to make some small change
and it also removes upstream
dependencies
on external systems like apis or
databases
to be live and be working if you just
want to do something really small
like change it fix the typo and you're
are marked down
you don't want to not be able to do that
just because for some reason your
database wasn't running
and one final note on projects there
exists a lot of great packages out there
to help you set up these projects and
some of them also have different
opinionated file structures
a little different maybe than the exact
one i showed here but very similar in
spirit
so i definitely encourage you to check
out use this project template and
starters to find the one that works best
for you
and also making a project is a great
time to think more
about managing your package dependencies
that are going into that project
and um next up after my talk is a talk
on rm
so you'll get to learn a lot more about
that shortly
so again stepping back a minute to take
take a view of where we are we now have
a pretty well refactored
analytical project as opposed to a file
and some benefits of this are that we
can easily like
we've really broken apart all sorts of
pieces that might be independently
useful
and put them in a place where they're
very easily found and accessed to be
repurposed but at the same time because
we're in sort of project mode
we've really preserved a lot of the
context specific to our individual
analysis
while doing this so for people that are
more interested
in building off of our analysis or
taking the actual like learnings
from what we were trying the question we
were trying to answer it's still very
easy to do that
however for that very reason projects
can still cause
some confusion because they kind of blur
the line sometimes
between what's a tool versus what's part
of a higher level
process that solves the class of
problems versus your individual problem
if you want to focus mostly on solving
that broad class of problems
that's when we can move to a full-blown
r package
to me one magical thing about our
packages
that i didn't realize when i first
started uh using r
was they're really simple is saving a
lot of our code
in the right places and there's pretty
clear one-to-one mapping
between the kind of structure you might
use for a project that i've talked about
previously
to the kind of structure you'd use for
an r package
all the functions that we just broke up
into separate r scripts
translate ease go right into a single r
folder
the actual markdown that we've been
working with this whole time
can actually serve numerous purposes it
can either go in your package
as in our markdown template so users of
your package
immediately have some code they can use
to start playing with
and experimenting with and a working our
markdown example
of how to use what you've built and they
can also be repurposed
as vignettes and long-form documentation
to truly teach people more deeply about
how to think about the problem
that they're working on similarly all
the data artifacts we created
if we're careful to anonymize them and
take out anything that we shouldn't be
sharing with the public
can be very useful as examples in your
data package
by shipping example data in the data
folder this gives us great way to build
more vignettes
to conduct unit testing and to give
examples
in your our oxygen documentation really
the only two things we're missing at
this stage
are a man folder where the documentation
manual lives
and the tests folder for unit tests
and at this point i doubt it should
surprise anyone here
that they're more radar packages to help
us go this last mile
first of all once again to use this
package is phenomenal for helping us set
up the package infrastructure we need
and making sure we do in fact save all
those individual package assets
in the right places with the right file
structures and configuration files
to make everything flow through
seamlessly devtools can automatically
generate
our our documentation from the
our oxygen comments that we have already
wrote
many steps back in this process and test
that provides a really friendly
interface
for doing unit testing which quite
honestly objectively if we want to trust
the outcome of any analysis we probably
even could have thought about doing
many steps earlier in this process
and beyond all of those absolute
requirements
r even goes above and beyond what we
need and there also exists package down
which can similarly reuse all of those
great assets you made
throughout your project and throughout
the art our
markdown driven development process and
create a very user-friendly
attractive polished website to help
people learn about
and use your analytical tool
so now we've created kind of the
spectrum of possible outputs
and possible analytical outcomes of our
markdown driven development process
i think all of us are probably very well
aware what incremental benefits the
package provides
it's of course one of the most formal
distribution mechanisms
especially if you have access to a
repository a cran
or cran-like repository to share your
work
or and it also adds benefits
because it provides a very formal and
familiar way
for people to learn about and engage
with your tool pretty much any our user
is used to working within our package
that said kind of the trade-off again
that exists here
is that at this point we've abstracted
very far away
from our initial problem and if simply
recreating your work
is you think that going to be the
primary goal of future users
then maybe we've gone a bit too far
so in summary no matter which path you
choose
our marked your original our markdown
analysis can be a great starting point
for a very wide variety of data products
and by leveraging all the work you did
in conducting your initial analysis
you're much closer than you may realize
to building a very sustainable and
empathetic data tool
thank you all very much for coming in
your time today
if you're interested in learning more my
i have a blog post on this topic that
you can find at
tiny dot cc slash rmdd
and if there's time remaining i'm happy
to take any questions
[Applause]
thank you emily that was excellent we
have time for just a couple questions
maybe just one
the most popular is how does this
workflow change if the end result is an
automated scheduled job
i think that probably can vary in a
couple of ways depending on how
complicated the job is i know um
i've been reading about and learning
about our studio connect some recently
and i think that actually has a lot of
good options for automation
based purely out of that original r
markdown so i think that could be
another good use case where the one file
arm markdown approach
even if it is handling kind of the full
etl process
is actually a good solution because it
can still um
some of the like re-running problems
aren't really problem
because rerunning your work is actually
what you're trying to accomplish
but for some more complicated batch
processes even if you're automating them
you'd still probably want to go all the
way and build the package
and then go back and use those the tools
you've created
to build the job if you want to like
have more robust and well-tested and
well-documented components to that batch
job great thank you again